from Sofia to crackle via Paris or
London a fog hangs over Europe a cloud
of pollution that not okay spoils the
landscape but has dramatic consequences
for people's health reserve I ritory
problems cardiovascular disease lung
cancer Europe has already said caps on
emissions from road traffic industry
agriculture and coal-fired power plants
like those used in Poland but it's not
enough each year air potion causes
400,000 premature deaths in the European
Union as part of you fools MVP's have
drawn up a list of five pollutants they
say should be subject to stricter caps
by 2030 I change to express it in terms
of improvement in health outcomes and
the total package across all Member
States will see by 2030 and improvement
in health outcomes 49.6 percent so
that's almost half of the problems that
we have now eliminated medical
procedures sick days falling
agricultural yields aside from the
health effects of air pollution the
economic costs are also considerable
amounted to 332 914 billion euros per
year these new climate targets now need
to be implemented by member states
between twenty twenty and twenty thirty